des touristes évacués sous escorte sur
l'autoroute celle épilogue à 21h30 d'une
séquence commencé dans l'après midi avec
une manifestation à l'aéroport des
syndicats et organisations connues
réclamant davantage de contrôles
sanitaires face au corona virus mais
quand les activistes fédérer autour des
blocages de supermarchés prennent la
main les organisations connues
disparaissent et le ton change
[Musique]
c'est ça ils ont d'abord tenté de
pénétrer sur le tarmac pour empêcher un
avion d'atterrir
leur cible l'avion qui devait
initialement amené ici des touristes
italiens pour embarquer sur un paquebot
de croisière il atterrit finalement à
vide c'est plus tard que les choses
dérapent des touristes allemands belges
et italiens sont emmenés en bus pour
rejoindre le navire au port le bus est
bloqué à deux reprises et finalement
arrêté au milieu de la nationale les
parois du bus sont tagués les pneus
dégonflés les touristes et le chauffeur
à l'intérieur après au moins deux heures
d'attentes les autorités tentent
d'évacuer les gens vers un autre bus
[Musique]
nous sommes entrés dans le bus et tous
les gens se sont mis à courir à heurter
le bus et à s'allonger sur le sol devant
le bus c'était complètement dingue tout
série parce que cette situation affecte
le monde entier le virus d'allemagne
nous sommes des gens normaux ne sommes
pas malade on n'a pas eu le moindre
contact avec le virus ne voyageant seuls
et nous sommes des gens responsables
nous ne venons pas ici avec l'objectif
de secte et les gens
moi même je suis docteur sam walsh les
touristes seront finalement évacué vers
l'ancienne aérogare où un bus finira par
les récupérer derrière le bâtiment
j'ai vu déjà un peu traumatisés qui sont
aujourd'hui donc là on parle hébergés à
l'ancienne et organes l'espace
aéroservices il ya des bus qui vont
venir les chercher pour les amener sur
le bateau et donc voilà ce qui est en
train de se passer et après quand ils
vont partir ben on va retrouver je
l'espère une activité normale d'un
aéroport qui consiste à concevoir des
passagers et à les accueillir et à les
faire voler à 22 heures les pompiers
éteignent un feu de palettes derrière
gagneront tandis que le msc s'en va
emportant à son bord les souvenirs d'une
escale un peu particulière